[Music]
hi everyone
uh welcome to this session that's about
optiva and cloud spanner
my name is deepti srivastav i'm the
product manager for cloud spanner in the
cloud databases and storage team and it
is my great pleasure
to open this session for all of us so
optiva previously red knee solutions is
a
telco-based software company and as
a lot of you may know telco systems are
some of the most demanding in the world
and
so as optiva looked to look to the cloud
to uh gain competitive advantage and
also to
embrace new technology they settled on
cloud spanner um
fairly quickly right um and
that's what we're here to talk about
today but before that so um
optiva uh has uh re-platformed
uh to use a cloud spanner for the new uh
billing and charging system
um and recently we announced a
partnership with optiva at mobile world
congress earlier this year
we're very excited about that
partnership it's a great partnership
um and we are um so uh
so grateful and so appreciate seeing
optiva actually
move a very traditional telco industry
into the cloud
we're also excited that they have moved
to gcp for their internal i.t services
as well
so to tell you all about this journey it
is my
great honor and pleasure to uh introduce
daniel royston awesome who is the ceo of
optiva
yeah welcome danielle hi thank you so
much
yeah thank you welcome everyone um as
thank you deepti for that great
introduction and hopefully the volume is
okay and i'm not
too loud i get really excited that's
kind of who i am
danielle royston everyone calls me dr by
my initials i'm not a doctor
i'm ceo of optiva as deep explained and
let me get my little
my little clicker here
so yeah so uh deepti was talking about
cloud spanner this is uh
google's enterprise database that we
have decided to start to use
and we're really excited about this
partnership right um google
obviously one of the best companies in
the world
and optiva is a little small company
about 120 million dollars of revenue uh
based in toronto canada i actually live
in austin texas
um and i became the ceo of this company
about
about 18 months ago and 18 months ago
this company was on the verge of
bankruptcy
right it was about to die we had about
100 customers
running our product and it worked
but the company kind of lost its way
what i do is i'm a turnaround ceo i go
in i'm kind of like uh winston wolf from
pulp fiction
i'm the fixer right i go in and i fix
problems and so
sat down and looked at the company
looked at our assets
what was working well what did customers
really like about us
what could we do better and one of the
things we looked at was
we could do more with the vision around
the product so we really started to
investigate that so as deep d explained
we make software for telcos and
specifically it's called
charging software uh it sounds boring as
hell
but and when i first came in i was like
what is this
what are we doing um but i'll explain
what that is in
in a second here so yeah that's me
that's my cool little uh my comments
because i'm coming to change change
everything in telco
all right so what is charging right um
everyone here i see everyone has a phone
um and all your phones have plans right
the telcos come up with
uh designs to get you to become a
subscriber that's like a customer to
them
uh number of minutes number of text the
amount of data
and so there's marketing teams that
design those plans to entice you to
become a customer
and stay with them and then as you're
making phone calls
as you're sending texts there's software
somewhere
usually sitting on their network usually
sitting on the ground
on premise that's tracking
your calls and deducting them from your
plan and so the united states is largely
a post-paid market meaning we pay at
you know we pay our bills after after
the month is over
but the world is largely a prepaid
uh market right most people are paying
for it ahead of time
and then when they're out of minutes or
out of data it stops you
right so this is um
uh it needs to be correct right it's a
very
technically difficult problem to solve
right they
it's revenue right so if the calculation
is ever wrong
these guys are not being able to
calculate
revenue which is obviously their
business
number two it's super high volume right
think of all the people in the country
uh right simultaneously
making calls and doing tech so lots of
value
volume going on and um
and it has to be low latency right so
when you make a call
right you're not going to sit there and
wait for the charging engine to return
you know in a minute it has to be
milliseconds of time
so it's a super difficult technical
problem to solve
and um i call it the trifecta of hard
right transactional integrity right
there has to be
computing correctly low latency and this
is high growth high volume
now all of us are or most of us
maybe i have a couple canadians but in i
i know i have a couple canadians but
you know we kind of think of the us as
like this really big market and it's
you know the world revolves around us
but the reality is
we are tiny compared to some of these
other markets
like india and china right and so
we have a customer located in india that
has
200 million subscribers and so imagine
all of us in the united states were just
one we just
had one telco we were all there and
there wasn't choices like verizon and a
t
and sprint and t-mobile right we have a
customer that is
basically the size of the united states
and so for them
um this is a
this is a really hard problem for us to
solve when we install our
product like i said traditionally on the
ground
we use oracle right oracle's known as
maybe the world's best enterprise
database it's super trusted
it works it handles a lot of volume and
for us
we can process in our engine about 50
000 transactions per second
which is a lot and that's good and
but for our india customer for example
it's not enough
and so our solution there is to stand up
copies of the implementation
around the country in india to handle
urban circles so think of a city
or a city area as an urban circle i have
12
12 implementations and so it's kind of
like 12 customers in one
right like i have a deli i have a mumbai
right kolkata right i have all these
different areas
where they are handling the traffic but
i need to have a consistent database
because people move
right you don't just stay in one spot so
these guys the database has to talk to
each other
i got to keep it up and so today we have
essentially 12
data centers with testing staging
production disaster recovery right
there's a really good story about
our customer where their um their data
center started to flood
in india and there was our team got
caught in the building
and they were just like lifting up the
machines
like off of the ground i guess that's
one way of
getting cloud um right but they just
started
like lifting the machines to save them
and our team actually
i just saw this video our team actually
got caught in the building for like
three days they slept there no food
like managing the machines all right
so like i said um 50 000 transactions
per second is pretty much
our limit um and uh you know
being a tough hard problem oracle really
owns the telco space
like they're everywhere and some of our
customers pay
between 10 million and 100 million
dollars a year
to oracle oracle is notoriously
difficult to do business with
right my customers have told me that
they try to get off and oracle just
increases the price
right so if you're paying 100 million
and you figured out a way to carve out
20
they figure out a way to still charge
you 100 million and so our customers
were like
you know what can we do now there's a
lot of database vendors out there
and we certainly looked at a lot of them
um but we were like
you know to really change this problem
and come up with a fresh idea we wanted
to
um think we went to the engineering team
and said could we make our product 10
times faster
right right assuming that there's
nothing
stopping you right change that oracle
change out
the coding rewrite the whole entire
engine what could we do
right sky is the limit and um
and we started to look at the database
right this is a right intensive
application
right it's not just you know look it up
return an answer sorry return an answer
to um to the user you actually have to
deduct
you know five minutes from the plan and
write it to the database
meanwhile you know if you're like me i'm
like texting
on my phone and then doing something on
my watch and you know i'm on my ipad
right so
you know atomically correct actions need
to be captured and written to the
database
and so uh we noticed that a lot of the
performance of our application was spent
writing to the database so that's kind
of got us like on the trail
of maybe we could do something with a
different database so we looked at a
bunch of different databases
and um and basically we're like you know
what can we do so we
around this time this is so i started in
february i think spanner was announced
in march valentine's day
okay that was the day i started optiva i
didn't realize that
so that was the day i started up tiva
and so we were looking we're like
what can we do how can we make this ten
times faster and we read the spanner
press release
and we're like are you kidding me
like this is our dream come true right
we have
a perfect database that can handle the
transactional volume
it's distributed it's consistent um
multiple writings right like uh
synchronized writing across
a thousand servers it's exactly what we
needed to replace
big bad oracle and it had the google
name
uh so that our customers were trusted
right i mean they're not going to just
switch to
you know not to disparage any databases
out there but
you know new db or mongodb or whatever
they need
my customers are like these are 10
billion companies they're like
we need a good strong name so we looked
at span and we're like
this could work this might work
so um called up my friends at google
dom dom's here i called i literally like
sent him an email and was like hey dom
you haven't heard from me and i don't
know 19 years
yeah but i just read this really awesome
press release
and we think it could work and it was
really new and so we put together
two teams and we just started working on
the problem right just
go right can you make it 10 times faster
and
it was pretty easy to make it 10 times
faster right we i'll talk about it a
second about like what we did
but um you know the fact is it was such
a game changer for telco that
we would have put our entire engineering
budget behind
getting it to work with spanner if it
was required
because it was such a revolutionary
database
so that was really cool so let's see
yeah so i have a demo here i'm going to
attempt to
click
all right um when can you go ahead and
switch it to the demo
so try to make performance like cool
and it's actually really hard uh for
performance to be cool
so um the other thing we wanted to do
besides making it ten times faster
is we wanted to make sure it was a tenth
of the cost it needed to be also
cheaper than oracle right so again these
the system works for the telcos it's
running their revenue
they're not going to move off of a
system if it's just two times faster
it's just not enough
or four times faster now it had to be
ten times faster so had to be big enough
for a reason to change
but the same time if it's ten times as
expensive they're also
not going to move so our second goal
that we started working on was
could we make it a tenth of the cost and
that's the beauty of the cloud
right that's the beauty of spanner so
what we have here
is this is a live demo right so it's not
a video it's a real demo
what you see over here are transactions
right these are call records of
users right you can see kind of what's
going on
right what they're using what's the
story is
over here is the transactions per second
and i bumped it up
right i actually need to bump it up a
little bit more it's
at 300. so this is live
and i'm gonna just take it up to
500 000 transactions per second
and so the engine what spanner is doing
is dynamically deploying nodes
in google cloud live right now to
to build up to this level so imagine
what happens in a country
when like an earthquake happens or you
know it's christmas day and everyone's
making their family calls
you get this temporary spike in usage
and then
you know or world cup right we just went
through world cup it's like a month long
lots more usage of video on the phone
but then after world cup
the the volume drops what
my customers do is they provision to
like
just above what they think they need
on their worst day because they get the
media attention
when they're down when things aren't
working so
they need to have data centers and the
capacity the compute
already hot and live plus the disaster
recovery for all of that
to be able to handle their their best
day or their worst day depending on how
you look at it
right what's so great about spanner
right
is that it's deploying dynamically so
maybe there was an unexpected
event you know a negative event in the
country terrorist attack
right uh uh earthquake you get these
spikes
and by running in the public cloud and
specifically running with spanner
i now no longer need to deploy
oracle instances now over here
is the big bad line of oracle spend
every time that's spiking i'm deploying
another
data center that's provisioned for
usually equal capacity
so if you're the customer in india right
you have a system running about and
handling about
50 000 transactions per second and now
you need to handle
more volume you have usually what they
do is they just set up another data
center that handles
that capacity you don't need all that
capacity but you pre-purchase
all the compute and all the power to be
able to handle that
what's nice about spanner is i can go
back down and all that spend comes back
down
so a lot of times when people look at
public cloud they
in for our industry for telco we're
really kind of behind everyone else
everyone's still running in closets
on site right maybe some have
virtualized
no one's in public cloud in fact when i
started
um my team was like don't don't talk
about google
don't talk about public cloud it's like
really bad they're never gonna do it
and i'm like this is insane like public
cloud is everywhere
it's absolutely coming to telco and so
it's like you know kind of behind but
now we're bringing them to the future
here right the cloud is
is now so they over provision they pay
for all the stuff with spanner
i don't have to do that and to show you
that it's live if i alt tab
over here this is the um google
product right showing the transactions
you can see at 11 whatever why does it
say 1145 maybe 12 45 moves off on the
time
it spiked when i moved it up um
the nodes i forget why the nodes are
consistent maybe sanka can remind me but
you can see the transaction so this is
live running
in google cloud someone's paying for it
probably me
i'll probably take down the transactions
after this because it's kind of too much
remind me to take it down but um
but yeah so this is this is a game game
changer for
for telco and um and for us so hold on
let me uh look at my notes one more time
um let's see here
i talked without
looking at my notes all right
so why does this oh actually go back
when to the
to the screen
awesome so why does this work right
so sure oracle can do clusters and can
kind of
replicate multi-writing but
the difference with spanner is i need to
be distributed across
like a thousand thousands of servers
right
and i need that strong consistency so
oracle can't do that right i mean
i can create a cluster of like maybe 50
oracle databases
but spanner's doing it all for me behind
the scenes
i have to have global scale right my
telcos have
multiple data centers right like my
india example has 12
but google i mean i have the whole
google
footprint right behind us billions of
dollars of investment
and i need to have performance at scale
i can't have a choke point
for my rights like i do with oracle and
so because
of spanner's true time functionality
where it's atomically synchronizing
all the rights this works for me so i'm
correct yes
oh i can't hear you
i don't have any chinese customers i
have an india customer
yeah okay cool yeah so
i forgot where i was but it's cool i'll
figure it out
so those three say that again
yes thank you deepti i lost i was like
where'd she go did she leave me
right so the true time piece and deepti
will be able to explain this much better
than me
but the whole idea behind true time is
the ability to write
um asynchronously and keep everything in
sync
atomically so i no longer have a choke
point like i do with oracle
and it's all being handled for me
dynamically which is
amazing um and we think that the last
piece the true time is really where
there's
technical differentiation here versus
versus oracle this is
this is not just any other database this
isn't marketing fluff that we fell for
you know oh we like google let's just
pick google's database we looked at a
bunch of different databases and we're
like these are three
distinct reasons that it's not only as
good as oracle which currently is
regarded as maybe one of the best
databases
it's actually better right and now it
supports the dynamic scaling that my
telcos need
so they're not provisioning data center
after data center at the same cost
right i'm saving them money and now my
promise of ten times faster
at a tenth of the cost is true so
again i'm in india my team's like don't
tell the story about oracle and
and public cloud and i'm like i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna talk about it this is
like an amazing idea
and i'm talking to the technical leaders
and their heads just spin when i tell
them
ten times faster to a tenth of the cost
they're like what did you say
and i was like yeah i i don't think
you'll be interested in it because
you're so big
you know you have your own data centers
my team tells me you'll never pick
public cloud they're like can we start a
proof of concept
tomorrow and so off we go
right and so that's when i knew we were
really on to a really
uh competitive differentiation for us as
a company
and we were going to really change the
landscape for for telco
all right migrating your application
like i said i think i said this earlier
for us it was pretty easy we had a
database layer in our application they
were we were able to just switch out
from basically sql to rpc and then we
started uh performance benchmarking it
and it was 10 times faster
i mean that sounds easy i'm sure if the
engineers that worked on it were here
they'd be like a little bit more went
into that work
but um i'd say within 90 days
we had a we had something that was 10
times faster and then within six months
we had something that was
10 times cheaper right so at first we
were deploying like a ridiculous number
of nodes
um and then later we um we got a little
bit more efficient so that was cool
um we think there's still room to make
this even
faster right so 10 times i mean like i
said my
it's turning heads i have a lot of
customers that are in the audience
right we spent time yesterday talking
about it you know they're excited about
it as well so
it's working for small telcos for super
big telcos
it's a really great idea we think
there's still
two more features of spanner that we
could do
to take it kind of to the next level if
we ever needed to
um they have an interesting parent-child
relationship with the data so you can
kind of bring your data closer together
so that when we do a lookup on a
particular customer's plan
it's a little bit faster and so we're
not doing that yet but we could
and then we could look at the way we're
designing our database transaction
boundaries so that it's a little bit
more efficient and
and optimized we haven't done that
right now we're really focused on
getting this older i mean this
application
is 15 years old right this isn't like
instagram
snapchat it's not this it's like old and
boring like i said at the beginning
right but it's running it's running
billions of dollars of
monetization for the telcos of the world
every telco has a product like this
some cases they have multiple products
running right so we think this is
incredible technology game changing
computer science
stuff um and so we're we're super
excited about that
[Music]
you